[Music]  some of the world's greatest athletes  make vast amounts of money the soccer  star Cristiano Ronaldo makes eighty  million dollars a year  counting salary and endorsements  basketball great LeBron James makes 72  million Tiger Woods the golfer earns 61  million in the year and tennis star  Roger Federer makes 56 million some  people argue that rich people like these  sports stars should be taxed to help the  poor others argue the taxation for  redistribution is unjust they say it is  admirable for rich people voluntarily to  help people in need but wrong for the  state to force them to do so what do you  think is it just or unjust for the state  to tax the rich to help the poor  you  [Music]